Es gibt eine neue wendung, im fall der verborgenen cummard der cheops-pyramide die. Im letzten jahr entdeckt wurde ein italienischer
astrophysiker und archäo astronomie
Jetzt eine wirklich spannende erklärung entwickelt was sich in der kammer verdrückten das scheint mehr als pure luft
Zu sein es wäre ein wirklich
Unglaublicher schatz was es ist und warum es sich dort verbergen soll jetzt sind klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja ich habe mich noch
mal mit der aussprache von jobs ein bisschen beschäftigt tatsächlich in
süddeutschland und österreich wird krebs gesagt deswegen sage ich in diesem video mal wieder shops und vielleicht demnächst mal wieder anders
anfang november
2017 haben wir darüber berichtet in der jobs pyramide wurde ein riesiger hohlraum entdeckt über den inhalt beziehungsweise dem zweck
Schießen die spekulationen jetzt ins kraut ob und es gibt eine erste forschungsarbeit das von einem renommierten
astrophysiker und archäo astronomie
Juli ist professor an der polytec nico in mailand und dort direktor der mathematischen fakultät
Astronomie ist ein spezialgebiet der archäologie und beschäftigt sich mit der
astronomischen bedeutung von relikten und bauten aus der vergangenheit und da ist ägypten
Natürlich eine wahre schatztruhe und vielleicht in diesem fall sogar, im wahrsten sinne des wortes
Juli hat sich jetzt mit dem hohlraum beschäftigt und ist zu sehr interessanten schlüssen gekommen aber erst noch mal zum hohlraum und wir entdeckt wurde
denn auch das ist schon eine absolute sensation
er wurde nämlich mit
Teilchenphysik entdeckt er wird schon als die entdeckung
Des jahrhunderts bezeichnet die kammer ist wirklich riesig 30 meter lange acht meter hoch und breit oberhalb der galerie
also das kann es der zur königs kammer führt und die entdeckung mit teilchenphysik funktionierte so
Millionen haben die kammern nachgewiesen sie entstehen wenn protonen aus dem weltall auf unserer atmosphäre treffen
Dabei zerfallen atomkerne und es entstehen diese million sie sind wie elektronen negativ geladen zerfallen aber bereits nach
22 millisekunden von außen betrachtet existieren sie aber viel länger die
relativitätstheorie macht es möglich bewegen sie sich fast mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
Fort deshalb wirkt die zeit delegation auf sie und sie haben für uns rund zehn
mal mehr zeit bis sie zerfallen in dieser zeit können sie die erdoberfläche
Erreichen auf dem weg durch materie werden sie dann abgelenkt fliegen sie nicht durch materie werden sie eben nicht april erstellt
man in einer pyramide also unterhalb eines hohlraums
Detektoren auf treffen dort mehr millionen auf als unter einer dicken stein schicht wie mit einem
So konstruierten heutigen gerät können jetzt hohlräume entdeckt werden und genau das ist jetzt passiert
Oberhalb der galerie muss es nach den messungen der teilchenphysiker zu sicheren einen
Hohlraum geben 30 meter lang und acht meter hoch und breit aber was verbirgt sich in dieser kammer
Hat sich erstmal mit der literatur beschäftigt und ist auf interessantes gestoßen seine quelle sind die pyramiden
Texte das sind texte die sich an den innenwänden der pyramiden und an den innenseiten der serie finden dort ist ein
Eiserner thron erwähnt auf dem zitat aus der forschungsarbeit
Der verstorbene pharao bevor er die nördlichen sterne erreicht die tore zum himmel passiert
Ja platz nehmen muss nun gibt es genau solche tore zum himmel der pyramide das jedenfalls vermutet man, dass
Sie genau diese tore sein können sie sind, am ende zweier schächte im süden und im norden das tor am ende
Des südlichen schachtes wurde schon genauer untersucht beim nördlichen schacht ist das aber noch nicht geschehen und er endet. Genau da
Wo der verborgene hohlraum vermutet wird also wo er so ungefähr sein können die genaue lage
Konnte nämlich bisher noch nicht ermittelt werden ja wenn es, so wäre dann könnte sich hinter diesem nördlichen himmels tor zum einen dieser
hohlraum befinden und zum anderen ein wirklich
unglaublicher schatz ein eiserner thron wäre so ziemlich der
unglaublichste und wertvollste schatz der vorzeit denn und das ist wirklich absolut
faszinierend damals konnte noch gar kein eisen aus eisenerz gewonnen werden die technik war einfach noch nicht entwickelt trotzdem
Gab es schon relikte und gibt es auch heute noch
Aus eisen und sie waren damals wahrscheinlich das wertvollste was man besitzen konnte das eis
Damals nannte sich himmels eisen und dafür gibt es einen
Faszinierenden und einfachen grund das eisen kam aus dem alle
Bot ja es stand von eisen methoden dieses eisen konnte nämlich schon relativ einfach bearbeitet werden war aber natürlich extrem selten
Mangels vermutung in der kammer befindet sich ein ton aus solchen reisen gebaut wie zum beispiel der thron von joops mutter
Hätte faires das heißt dass die konstruktion aus holz ist er aber mit eisen verkleidet werden während andere forschungsteams
vorschlagen irgendwie mit endoskopen durch das gestein in den neuen hohlraum
Zu gelangen hat magie jetzt einen ganz konkreten plan die himmels tore also himmelstor, man
Weiß es ja nicht ob sie sehen wir sind am ende
Des nördlichen ganz sollen genauer untersucht werden er kann sich vorstellen dass man so zur geheimen kammern gelangt und dann
Diesen unglaublichen schatz entdecken wird das ist ja mal eine konkrete idee und vielleicht wird dann schon bald weiter
Geforscht wenn es neuester so gibt dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier wenn er kein video dazu und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
Dann wird mir hier kein abo aufsaugen vergessen ich denen
Genau auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter also hier dafür draufklicken
mysteriöses rätsel um nasca linien
endlich gelüftet ja und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran